without taking cheap political shots can
we talk about covid-19
how will
history remember the covid-19 pandemic
what were the successes were what were
the failures of leadership
of of man of humans
Doom was a book that I was planning to
write before yes the pandemic struck as
a history of of the future based in
large measure on science fiction
it occurred to me in 2019 that I had
spent too long not reading science
fiction and so I decided I would
liven up my my intake
by getting off history for a bit and
reading science fiction
because history is great at telling you
about the perennial problems of power
Putin is always interesting on History
he's become something of a historian
recently with his essays and lecturers
but what history is bad at telling you
is well what will the effects of this
discontinuity of Technology be
so I need some science fiction to think
more about this because I'm I'm I'm
tending to miss the importance of
technological discontinuity
if you read a lot of Science Fiction you
read a lot of of plague books because uh
science fiction writers are really quite
fond of the plague scenario so the world
ends in many ways in science fiction but
one of the most popular is the lethal
pandemic so when when the first
email came to me I think it was on
January the 3rd from my medical friend
Justin stebbing funny pneumonia in Wuhan
my antennae began to tingle because it
was just like
one of those science fiction books that
begins in just that way
in a pandemic
as Larry brilliant the epidemiologist
said many years ago the key
is early detection and early action
that's how you deal with a novel
pathogen
and almost no Western country did that
we know it was doable because the
Taiwanese in the South Koreans did it
and they did it very well
but really no Western Country got this
right
some were unlucky because super spreader
events happened earlier than in other
countries Italy was hit very hard very
early for other countries the real
disaster came quite late Russia which is
only relatively recently had a really
bad experience
the lesson for me is quite different
from the one that most journalists
thought they were learning last year
most journalists last year thought
Trump is a terrible president he's
saying a lot of crazy things it's his
fault that we have high excess mortality
in the United States
the same argument was being made by
journalists in Britain Boris Johnson dot
dot dot Brazil Jared bolsonaro dot dot
dot even India Narendra Modi the same
argument
and I think this argument is wrong in a
few ways it's true that the populist
leaders said many crazy things and
borrowedly speaking gave poor guidance
to their their populations
but I don't think it's true to say
that with different leaders these
countries would have done significantly
better if Joe Biden had magically been
president a year earlier I don't think
the U.S would have done much better
because the things that caused excess
mortality last year weren't presidential
decisions they were utter failure of CDC
to provide testing that definitely
wasn't Trump's fault Scott gottlieb's
book makes that very clear it's just
been published recently we utterly
failed to use technology for contact
tracing which the Koreans did very well
we didn't really quarantine anybody
seriously there was no enforcement of
quarantine and we exposed the elderly to
the virus as quickly as possible in
elderly care homes and these things had
very little to do with presidential
incompetence
so I think leadership
is a somewhat marginal importance in a
crisis like this because what you really
need is your public health bureaucracy
to get it right and very few Western
Public Health bureaucracies got it right
could the president have given better
leadership yes
his correct strategy however was to
learn from Barack Obama's Playbook with
the opioid epidemic the opioid epidemic
killed as many people on Obama's watch
as covert did on Trump's watch
and it was worse in the sense because it
only happened in the U.S and each year
it killed more people than the year
before over eight years nobody to my
knowledge has ever seriously blamed
Obama for the opioid epidemic
Trump's mistake was to put himself front
and center of the response to claim that
he had some unique insight into the
pandemic and to say with every passing
week more and more foolish things until
even a significant portion of people
who'd voted for him in 2016 realized
that he'd blown it which was why he lost
the election
the correct strategy was actually to
make Mike Pence
the pandemics are and get the hell out
of the way that's what my advice to
Trump would have been in fact it was in
February of last year
so the mistake was to to try to lead
but actually leadership in our pandemics
almost a contradiction in terms what you
really need is your public health
bureaucracy not to [ __ ] it up and they
really really [ __ ] it up and that was
then all blamed on Trump yes you know
Jim fallowes writes a piece in the
Atlantic that says well being the
president's like flying a light aircraft
it's pilot error and I I read that piece
and I thought does he really after all
the years he spent writing think that
being president is like flying a light
aircraft I mean it's really nothing like
flying a light aircraft being present is
you sit on top of a vast bureaucracy
with how many different agencies 60 70
we've all lost count and you're
surrounded by advisors at least a
quarter of whom are saying this is a
disaster we have to close the borders
and the others are saying no no we have
to keep the economy going that's what
you're running on in November
so being the president in a pandemic is
a very unenviable position
uh because you actually can't you can't
really determine whether your public
health bureaucracy will get it right or
not you don't think to push back on that
just like being Churchill in a war is
difficult
so leaving Trump abiding aside what I
would love to see from a president is
somebody who makes great speeches and
arouses the public to push the
bureaucracy the public health
bureaucracy to get their [ __ ] together
to fire certain kinds of people to do I
mean I'm sorry but I'm a big fan of
powerful speeches especially in the
Modern Age with the internet it can
really move people instead the lack of
speeches
resulted in certain kinds of forces
uh amplifying division over whether wear
masks or not or do all it's like it's
almost like the public picked some
random topic over which to divide
themselves and there was like a complete
indecision which is really what it was
fear of the of uncertainty materializing
itself in some kind of division and then
you almost like busy yourself with the
red versus blue Politics as opposed to
some I don't know FDR type character
just stands and say uh [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] that we're hearing we're going
to manufacture five billion tests this
is what America is great at we're going
to build the greatest testing
infrastructure ever built or something
or even with the vaccine development but
that was what I was about to interject
yes in a pandemic the most important
thing is the vaccine if you get that
right then you should be forgiven for
much else and that was the one thing the
Trump administer registration got right
because
they went around the bureaucracy with
operation warp speed and achieved a
really major success
so I think the Paradox of of the the
2020 story in the United States is that
the one thing that mattered most the
Trump Administration got right
and it got so much else wrong that was
sort of marginal that we were left with
the impression that Trump had been to
blame for the whole disaster which
wasn't really quite right
sure it would have been great if we did
Operation warp speed for testing But
ultimately vaccines are more important
than tests and
this brings me to the question that that
you raised there of polarization and why
that happened now in a book called the
square and the tower I argued that it
would be very costly for the United
States to allow the public sphere to
continue to be dominated by a handful of
big tech companies that this ultimately
would have more adverse effects than
simply contested elections and I think
we saw over the past 18 months uh just
how bad this could be because
the odd thing about this
country is that we came up with vaccines
with 90 plus percent efficacy and about
20 of people refused to get them and
still do refuse
for reasons that seem best explained
in terms of the anti-vaxx network which
has been embedded on the internet for a
long time predating the pandemic
renidaresta wrote about this
pre-2020 and this this anti-vaxx network
has turned out to kill maybe 200 000
Americans who could have been vaccinated
but were persuaded through magical
thinking that the vaccine was riskier
than the virus whereas
you don't need to be an epidemiologist
you don't need to be a medical scientist
to know that the virus is about two
orders of magnitude riskier than the
vaccine
so again leadership
could definitely have been better
but the politicization of everything
was not Trump's doing alone it happened
because our public sphere has been
dominated by a handful of platforms
whose business model
inherently promotes polarization
inherently promotes fake news and
extreme views because those are the
things that get the eyeballs and the
screens and sell the ads I mean this is
now a common place but when one thinks
about the cost of allowing this uh kind
of thing to happen it's now a very high
human cost and we were foolish to leave
uncorrected these structural problems in
the public sphere that were already very
clearly visible in 2016.